each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so today we're very happy to have
Claudia orlandi visiting us from Aarhus
University in Denmark and he's going to
talk about some recent results on
multi-party computation thank you very
safe for the introduction so yes Melissa
said I'm going to tell you something
about multi-party computation for des
amis majority and we're going to show
how to get from passive to active
security at low cost and this is a joint
work with even damn garden espa Nielsen
that are my advisor in both so if you
play poker online nowadays what you do
is that you're sitting at home without
another bunch of people sitting at their
home and the you're connecting to a
central server that shuffle a deck can
gives you your hand and then you can
play poker online what happens is that
you are putting the trust into the
central server so what happens if for
some reason the server is corrupted and
is colluding with some of the player
surely the server might pick your hands
at random but then he might pick the
hand of his friend in a corrupted way
and then give him a good hand and then
is going to steal your money so
multi-party computation see here
multi-party computation is a the area of
cryptography that tries to solve these
kind of problems where instead of
putting trust in sin into a central
server into a centralized entity what we
do is basically we emulate this trusted
computer by putting a small piece of
software or opal small piece of software
remotely at each of the parties computer
and those piece of software going to
compute something that hopefully is
going to be do the same as this trusted
central entity in such a way that
everyone will get a fair hand and then
the game is going to be fun so what I'm
going to tell you is first of all I'm
going to tell you what secure
multi-party computation is about and
which model of security we are going to
consider then I'm going to tell you
something about the related work in the
last 20 years and
and then I'm going to describe our
solution that it's basically computing
on shared commitments and then I'm going
to tell you how to do this in a say Hugh
way and then I'm going to give you some
sketch of the security analysis please
even the same answer just the same
probability distribution as an honest
yeah yeahs was just yet it was just an
example so other examples of multi-party
computation that are actually used in
your life are electronic auctions that's
something we have been looking at
especially in Denmark we had this
electronic auction for a sugar beet
price I'm in that case also that the
output needed to be correct because the
output was actually the price at which
you would exchange the sugar bits it's
actually funny that the first that was
the first application of multi-party
computation in real life and it had to
do with agriculture so we are going back
to the basics all right so what do I
mean when I say that I wanna have secure
multi-party computation what do I mean
by secure so first of all correctness we
will like the output of the computation
to be correct so for instance the
epochal cards are random and then we
also want privacy so we don't want any
information about your input to be
leaked so in this case you don't I don't
want you to know what my hand is
otherwise pocket is not fun but they're
also other security requirements for
instance if you are playing poker you
can imagine that someone is playing on
two tables at the same time and you
don't want them to get cards from one
table and play them on the other table
right so instead of listing a series of
requirements of security requirements
what the cryptographic community has
been doing in the last 20 years is to
have this ideal world we all were the
security definition kind of so we first
we define an ideal world where we have a
trusted entity that we actually trust
that is programmed to run some
computation on parties input then the
parties will just deliver their input to
the center entity that will compute the
output of the function and just deliver
it to each party's
and in this setting if one of the
parties corrupted and tries to do
something that is not supposed to do
well the center entities frosted so it's
just going to say that guy's trying to
cheat and we just kick him out of the
computation or something like that so in
this scenario security is is a chip by
definition and then we have the real
world where instead of having the center
entity we are running this multi-party
protocol where the parties are
exchanging some encrypted garbled
messages and then we want this protocol
to be secure as the idle word so we said
that a particle is secure if empirically
the real world behaves like the idle
word that means that as we formalize by
saying that that versary cannot
distinguish in which word is so if that
versary whatever attack that vessel you
can do in the real world you can also do
in the idle word then the real world is
here because there is not tacky can do
in the other word and we want this
property to be satisfied no matter how
Wiggly that Versailles behaves so we
want to be sure that the security holes
that that versary might deviate from the
protocol as much as you like so to
define these we have to introduce a new
party that is called the simulator and
the simulator is kind of a bridge
between the real world and the idle
world so the simulator is going to
interact with the idol world this is a
mental experiment to prove the security
of the prodigal we are going to use this
new part is called the simulator that
week on that we the protocol designer
controls that is gonna interact with the
other world and see the input-output
behavior of the other word and we'll try
to run the protocol with this adverse I
here and he has to make that Versailles
believes that is actually playing this
game so the way to define securities
that we get that verse sorry we let him
play with the real game where is
interacting with other parties and we
let him play all we let him play there
either game where there is a simulator
and Inter is interacting with other word
through the simulator so we flip a bit
and either we put that verse in this
situation
this situation will let him run as much
as he wants and then we asked him where
are you playing and if that versa you
can not distinguish between these tours
then we say that the protocol is secure
so actually in this light that is just
one adversary but what we want to what
really what we really want here is that
12 security when actually all but one
parties are corrupted so and this is
particularly interesting in the case for
instance of two-party computation so if
we are into clearly as soon as one part
is corrupted everyone but you is
corrupted and also in the case of
multi-party computation turns out that
we have to pay some price in order to
get the multi-party computation secure
against a dishonest majority so given
that we are focusing on the case of
general functionality so we want to
provide a protocol that computes any
functionality we cannot guarantee a
determination or fairness where by
termination I mean that the other that
that versary can just run away from the
protocol and then the protiv is not
going to finish and by fairness I mean
that the adversary might choose to learn
his input and then after he sees his
input it can choose whether you are
going to see your input or not so that
verse re-learn this is sorry this output
that verse i learned is output and then
you can run away this is it's impossible
to fairness is clearly a nice property
the one we would like to achieve for
multi-party computation unfortunately
it's impossible to achieve it for
general functionalities there's been
some recent work by gordon in junk arts
and other people about special class of
functionalities where you actually can
that you actually can compute with the
fairness but that's outside the scope of
this talk so we have been working for
our people have been working on
multi-party computation for more than 20
years now or no yeah starting by Yau in
82 and the protocol by Jen w in 87
Gavaskar mccallion with Justin those are
feasibility results so here the problem
of to partying and multi-party
computation have been defined and solved
for the case of
computational security in standalone and
those solution are secure against a
dishonest majority standalone meaning
that the the protocol is guaranteed to
be secured just if you run one instance
of the protocol up the time so for
instance if you play truth table of
pocket at the same time there might be
some problem then there's been some work
on information theoretic security later
on and in order to get this kind of
security so here the security holes just
if that verse that is computationally
limited here the security fields no
matter how are powerful that verse is
but here you need to assume that there
is an honest majority so clearly the
solution are not interesting for the
heads of two-party computation for
instance and then after more recently
the definition of you see security has
been introduced and this is the
definition of security we are going to
go for where you see means Universal
composable and you see security we have
a very strong security guarantee that
says that no matter how many protocols
are running parallel over the network
and so this is but especially useful
over the Internet where you don't know
while i'm running a protocol with you I
don't know whether you're running other
protocols or maybe I'm running other
protocols and we want the security so if
a protocol is securing the you see sense
then its security will keep being
satisfied no matter how many products
are running at the same time in this
solution this was the first visibility
results for you see security and against
a dishonest majority but the use of
generic zero knowledge proofs makes this
protocol just is answell so we can do
npc but it does not give you a way of
going down and implementing it on the
line of efficient multi-party
computation protocols securing the UC
framework against dishonest majority and
with some kind of efficiency there's
been some work by Crammer damn garden
nielsen in 2002 2003 where you can
compute any electric secrets but yet the
solution is based on a threshold
threshold oma morphic encryption in
particular meaning pally
encryption scheme and this kind of
scheme and here does the setup
assumption is that at the beginning of
the time there is someone that gives
that generates a public key and then
give c shares of the secret key to all
depart participant of the prodigal
unfortunately there isn't really any
good efficient way so far too to
generate this shared set up without
going to a trusted party so generating a
pally a public key and and with the
shares it's a it's still something that
requires some heavy machinery and then
there's been some work by Lind L Pincus
ish I Minaj and emits I and buy myself
an instant on efficient multi-party
computation for bhudev circuits so those
are like so the first solution here was
yahoo in that a tissue and those
solutions are all about how to get yahoo
Yaga basic ways to work in the UC
framework against the active adversaries
and in an efficient way while in this
paper that i'm going to present now and
then this work by the same authors here
in that appear that TCC dizzy last year
a solution for arithmetic circuits has
been proposed the efficient the way that
our work compares to this one is
asymptotically we have the same
complexity but our constant are smaller
well while they get the result of more
general assumptions and then there's
been some working trying actually trying
to go and get these protocols and
implementing them so probably the first
one was fair play by the theme in haifa
with benefiting Kison esteem and they
have this i believe you can download it
from the website and they have solution
for boolean circuits for to party and n
parties with passive security then
lindell Pincus and I just marked at this
they implemented this this paper that
appeared at your hip 2007 where you can
get the two-party computation against
active adversaries
and then in the world of arithmetic
circuits the first power has been with
anolis with the first solution it was
for empathy computation first against
passive adversity than against active
adversary but still requiring a harness
majority and now we're implementing what
I'm going to present you so that brings
the beat that fills the gap between
honest majority and dies down as
dishonest majority and the results
another group in Estonia entire to that
they have this other framework called
share mind where they have some similar
results to what we are doing so the
comparison between arithmetic and
boolean multi-party computation is not
totally clear because when you have
computing arithmetic sink if you compute
arithmetic circuits additions are easy
multiplication are easy but on other
operations like for instance comparisons
harder to are less efficient to to to be
performed while bulan circuits are
really good that compare values or doing
doing a quality and I mean any bull and
circus but then it's they are less
efficient when it comes to addition or
multiplication so there is a trait of
fear and which solution you get which
solution uses should be thought I mean
application depending on the application
electron interesting we're actually also
working together with the fair play
people in order to try to merge the two
solutions and maybe jump from arithmetic
to boolean and do everything in the
domain where it's more efficient okay so
let me start with describing our
solution so first of all let's assume
that there is a public key for our
Patterson commitment scheme that is
available to all parties this is just a
random string so we assume that this is
is it that we have this public key in
the sky it comes from the sky no one
knows the discrete log of a gin-based G
but this is really just random string so
it can be conflict or
generated somehow and then I'm going to
use the notation X in a box to say to
wright-patterson commitment of X using
randomness art and then we have any
parties every party has a share X I and
the share I of the value that is
commitment committed end of the
randomness used in the commitment now if
you have two shared commitments like
this it's actually really easy to
compute addition of these values so if
you have our commitment of X and the
commitment of Y and you want to compute
a commitment of X plus y it turns out
that each party just needs to add their
own shares locally and this is really if
you have to do a lot of perdition this
means that additions basically come for
free in order to do multiplication is a
bit more tricky because just multiplying
your local share is not going to work
but what we can do is that assuming that
we have a trusted guy that gives you a
multiplicative 3pod triplets a b c where
c is the product of a times B so this
guy gives you just gives to the people
just random three plates of this form
then you actually can compute a new
multiplication of few times V and the
result is w just by doing two openings
and by doing a linear combination of the
of the results clearly if they we are
back to square one because it now if
this guy is corrupted Andy colludes with
some of the parties in the the prodigal
what we can do is that you can
communicate a B and C to this guy and
given that here this this values you
minus a and B minus B are public from
these values and amb the corrupted guy
can learn UV and W so basically the
problem of now our problem is to replace
this guy by a multi-party computation
protocol that is
do the same thing as these guys doing so
giving out three plates of
multiplicative commitments in a trusted
way I not here so basically this all
this thing can be free process it and
that's something that we like because
this everything I told you so far like
if we have this rustic guy then doing
multi-party computation is really really
efficient doing addition is just doing
some local editions and do
multiplication is just opening to
commitments and this this is quite nice
because then everything we are going to
do and all the products that are going
to scribe from now on is not doesn't
depend on the function you want to
compute around or the input of the
computation so you can just type this
guy computing these three plates at
sorry overnight and then share them to
the between the people and then in a
week from now we will compute something
and the actual online computation is
going to be really efficient why the
offline this pre-processing part is
going to be slightly more involved so
let's see how to actually do these
random multiplications we will start by
taking any passive secure protocol for
multiplication in that p where p is the
order of this group so to be honest when
I say take any passive secure protocol
there aren't really that many candidates
out there and most of them would would
work using your mom Orphic encryption
there are other solution based on other
assumption like coding theory assumption
and other but this is what given that we
are actually going to implement this
protocol that seemed to be the best
solution for us so Hank we are going to
look at palio crypto system where there
is an encryption algorithms and
encryption algorithm and the nice thing
about Polly is that is this oma morphic
meaning that if you get you cipher text
and encryption of X and encryption of y
and we multiply them together what
they're going to get is an encryption of
X plus y ma join so here we have some
kind of mismatching because they the
modulo that we are working in the
commitment
speed this is a prime number while the
model that we are working that that
palliative system works is M is a big
essay module is the product of two large
primes so we're going to we will need to
do something about it so i'm going to
write an eye for p is public key
everyone has his own public key public a
secret keeper and i'm going to assume
that the public key modulus are they are
much bigger than the prime using the
computation this assumption actually
makes sense in the real world because as
the group that we used to do the pedicel
commitment we can use an elliptic curve
group of points and while and elliptic
curve cryptography given that we don't
know how to break the discrete log in
sabes financial time that means that
basically if you pick p to be a number
of i don't know 160 bits or 200 bits
you're going to have the same security
as the projective to system for another
say module of size two thousand bits so
there is actually a big gap in the in
there and we are going to use this gap
as actually in a functional way during
our protocol so let's look at this
simple semi honest multiplication
protocol so we have one party that has
his own shares a 1 and b 1 the other
party as H would be to and what they
want to compute is c1 and c2 such that
the sum of c1 and c2 is the product of a
times B so the first party can send an
encryption of his own share under his
own public key to the other party that
can multiply beat you inside the cipher
text and then mask the result with some
randomness then we can do the other
thing the other way around and now the
party can compute their shares of c 1
and c 2 and then at the end they can
just commit to their shares and exchange
a shirt i'm assuming yet that the
parties are semi harness meaning that
they they follow the protocol as they
are supposed to and then they will try
to learn some information from this
protocol but so the parties are always
going to do what they are supposed to do
here so you can just let them commit and
say this is the this is the result i'm
committing to this one why is this
protocol secure against a semi honest
advice re well this part
he's an encryption of a one and his
encryption policy semantics a huge so
it's not learning anything about a one
and what happens inside is
multiplication is that as I told you I
assume that n is much bigger than P and
therefore and I'm going to choose D in a
some big range and therefore when i
compute a times B plus D module and this
is the same as an integer this is the
same as integer computation this number
is small compared to em so there is no
model reduction so this is really just a
a small number plus a big number and
therefore this result here is going to
be statistically close to uniform in 0
piece p cube so what these parties is
when it flips this value is doesn't
depend on be so it's not learning an
information that's perfect but of course
parties here can cheat they can send
when at the end of the project they can
send commitments to other values it
could be true they could be choosing
this a 1 and B 2 and D want to not in
the range that are supposed to be but in
bigger range so we need to force parties
to behave in a semi honest way of course
we could use zero knowledge proofs but
for it that that's a good solution in
theory but not really in practice
especially these range proof so if I'm
if I'm encrypting a value between 0 and
p and I have to prove you that this the
diseases that what I encrypted the small
value these range proofs are really
really expensive in practice so instead
of going for the zero knowledge approach
we are going to go for this efficient
cutting choose approach that inspired by
this previous work of us that legal for
two parties a huge computation where we
had basically some that's some similar
result to the one and presenting but for
boolean circuits and the cost of these
efficient cut and choose is going to be
just a small constant factor with
respect to the semi- protocol so let's
see how to do this
so first of all we let the parties
generate a lot of this multiplicative
triplet using the same i honest protocol
like 1 million of these triplets and of
course in some of these triplets the
adversary might be choosing to cheat and
learn some information so when there is
a scholar it means that that verse is
some extra information or these triplets
was generated done in a correct way so
the first step is we are going to check
a bunch of these triplets in order to
detect cheating so we ask all the
parties we generate 1 million triplets
and then we we can't flip a subset a
random string that defines a subset of
this and we just check that everything
everyone reveals all the randomness
they've been using during the protocol
and if everything matches if every party
was behaving correctly we we accept and
we proceed if you detect some cheating
with just about the protocol and we stop
yep you have each part will get to this
own set of of samples to look at we show
these commitments and it depends the
two-party case it's enough if you just
exchange randomness if you're in parties
so you have to do a small coin flip like
the one part is to commit then everyone
else since the randomness and then you
open a commitment otherwise the last
party could just buy us the set towards
his own
ah not really yeah we didn't think of it
it seems that with one random motive in
direct interaction doesn't I mean it's
not worth making too many because each
one of this what really is killing that
the performance of this or like what's
really the bottleneck of this is
generating these triplets because that
involves pally pally encryption
decryption and those this is the big
thing so what really want to minimize is
the number of three phase that we
generate so after we generated these
triplets we are going to randomly
partition the remaining triplets that
some of them are going to be correct
some of them are going to be maybe still
maliciously generated and you're going
to put a partition them in small sets of
size 2t plus one and now we are going to
combine them in order to to distill some
good three plates from a bunch of
possibly maliciously generated triplet
in order to do this what we do release
that we go back to some music has
sharing and we are gonna in a way I
guess the the main idea is that we are
going to do a Shamu secret we are going
to do a symmetrical sharing Rico's
fraction over these triplets so show me
she has sharing gives you privacy up if
up to some of the up to certain
threshold of the shares are leaked and
that's what we are going to use so we
have a bunch of these commitments some
of them are known to that verse sorry
but most of them are not and then when
you combine them together using sham
ishika sharing what you actually get is
a bunch of new commitments where the
content is unknown to that vessel in
practice this is just taking a linear
combination of this of this commitment
and now i'm going to show you why this
works
so in summation car sharing we have we
started with two random polynomials f of
X and G of X of degree less or equal
than T such that in F of 0 and in G of 0
we have this we have some secret to and
some secret be and then if you consider
the product polynomial H of X equal to f
of X times G of X this is a new
polynomial of degree 2 T and in and this
polynomial evaluated in zero contains
the value u times V so what we are going
to do is we are going to generate a
random bunch of coefficients for the
poly for the first polynomial and for
the second polynomial trying to get to
compute the product of the two original
secrets so we're going to fight define
these two committed polynomials
committed f of X and committed G of X
that are actually that actually everyone
can evaluate in public because the
unknown X is in the clear so you can
when you get the coefficient of the our
eyes and you you can evaluate f of X in
any point you can you can get a
commitment to the value of f of X in any
point in the same for G of X
so now what we want to do is that we
want to we have points over the
polynomial f endpoints of at the
polynomial G and we want to get points
of a de polynomial age so that we can
reconstruct H and reconstruct the the
product two times P so we let all the
parties evaluate the polynomial f and
the polynomial g on to t plus 1 points
and and for each one of these points we
are gonna do this multiplication using
one of the original three plates that we
computed before okay so now this multi
if these three plates was generated
correctly was generated in a semi
honnest way at the beginning then this
multiplication is secure and the values
f vy g of I and HIV will still be secret
if these three plates was generated in a
malicious way maybe that verse diagnose
AMV Danny we learn these two points but
our hope is that that verse i knows few
of these points so we learn few of these
points that will not allow him to
reconstruct the secret h of G 0 so after
we do this multiplication we have a
bunch of points over the H polynomial
age of 12 h of 2t plus 1 and that
determines the polynomial H of X of
degree less or equal than cutie and
given that we have to t plus 1 points we
can reconstruct the value of this
polynomial in 0 that is U times V and
this is just a linear combination of the
day of the coefficients of these points
any question
in BTW what you do is you do this
multiplication on some on the shares
that we have so BTW we have a bunch of
players you assume that a majority of
those are honest then you do the
multiplication and given that that
versary knows less than T points of it
on the polynomial it doesn't learn the
secret what we do here is somehow
different we say we generate instead of
the parties engine v cw's correspond to
our three plates so when you generate
the three plates each one of these three
pets is like a party in this BTW
protocol that we run in a way we are
running BTW we are learning like a two
layer protocol so we have a protocol for
designers majority on a protocol for
honest majority on top of another
protocol for des honest majority ok so
why is this secure let's let's play this
game so i put here in front of you see
buckets of sea of size 2t plus one ok
and then i asked you to prepare a box
full of balls we are going to put green
bolts and red balls inside this box I
cannot see what's inside the box the box
is sealed and you can choose how many
red balls and how many green balls to
put inside the box so green bolts are
three plates where you didn't cheat and
red balls are three plus where you
cheated now I put a hand in depth in the
in the box and I start extracting balls
and if I see a red one you lose that is
the check that you are doing at the
beginning we open half of the three
plates if I see that you see that you
lost the game you are the dresser of
course and
if I don't see any red ball we go to the
second phase of the game and the second
phase of the game I opened the box and I
start putting bolts at random from the
box inside the buckets so the first ball
goes there the second ball goes here the
third ball goes there and so on at the
end of the game you win if you didn't
lose before and if any of these buckets
as a majority of red balls so if you
play this game now how many Red Bulls
will be put in the box what's your
optimal strategy to to win this game
this is an exercise and more or less the
best strategies to put something like
1.5 times the size of the bucket so we
can bound the probability that vessel is
going to win our game and the
probability device is going to win is
soft is less than 1 over the number of
buckets I put their raised to the size
of the buckets and we can make this
small as we want the nice thing is that
we get security not just by the size of
the buckets but also from the number of
the backers that means that this
approach our approach works better if
you compute bigger functionalities so if
you want to do 1,000,000 multiplication
instead of 100 modification the
replication factor is going to be
smaller and smaller the more
multiplication you do the more complex
the computation you are performing the
more efficient it gets and that is nice
because usually these automatic circuits
are quite big when you turn you know
like we have like real life problems
into our it many secrets they get big
and so it's actually it's a nice feature
so this is what I showed you so far is
how to get one good multiplication one
good three plates out of a bunch of
triplets actually if instead of using
some musical sharing we use the packs a
musical sharing so we're instead of
embedding one secret inside a polynomial
we embed a bunch of secrets inside the
polynomial then we can get these numbers
to be much better
instead of distilling one good triplets
from one set with still a constant
factor like one-fourth of good three
plates out of each set so I level
overview of the proof so showed you the
bell game from the ball game we know
that if I don't when when we start we
open a check out of the triplets if you
didn't if I didn't see any good any bad
the trip as that means that there are
few bad triplets if you go to the second
stage of the game it means that you
didn't put too many otherwise if you put
a lot of but if you misbehave too if you
misbehave too often i'm going to catch
you with a probability if you might
behave just a few times they're going to
be a few bad triplets that are going to
so we are going to have less than T by
three plays per per set and that means
that that very signals less than T
points on each polynomial and that means
that he has no information on UV UV from
sham you see her sharing there is one
extra step that you have to take to get
to achieve you see security so one one
of the security requirements for you see
intuitively is that parties have to
prove that they know their inputs these
has to do with the with no malleability
this has to do with the fact that you
want to be sure that if if a party is
playing with on more protocols at the
same time you cannot get some
information from one protocol like some
cipher text from one protocol and
forward forward to the other protocol so
every time they input something they
have to prove that they know actually
those values and so so what we do it
again instead of giving proof of
knowledge of these values we basically
pre-processed knowledge by generating
some random you see patterson commitment
i'm going to tell you now what those are
and ask people to open differences
between these random you see commitments
and the pedestal commitment that we use
doing the protocol so basically p I is
going to generate some you see
commitment are
and I you see and and by generating this
you see commitment is going to prove
that he knows our and then when he wants
to input a value a it just opens the
difference between this should be our or
should show this should be expects you
choose which one so it's going to open
the difference between these random
commitment and the actual value and
opening this difference is it's a proof
of knowledge of the fact that he knows
the the value ISM is actually giving as
a input to the prodigal so how do we
generate this you see Feddersen
commitment that can be used together
with the standard producing commitment
so we start again from a semi honest you
see commitment we look it we assume that
there is a common first ring in the sky
that contains four group elements and
the you see commitment of X with
randomness r and s is going to be of
this form this is basically an El Gamal
encryption in the first two places and
then there is a patterson commitment
down here when when you want to open one
of these commitments you're going to
send the value X and this so are the
values during the el-gamal encryption is
never is actually never revealed so the
sender sends this value and the receiver
checks that this component is consistent
with this opening so why do we have this
first part if we never use it because
when we go and do the security proof
what happens is that the simulator is
going to choose the common refrain
string and therefore he knows the
trapdoor so the discrete log of G to
invest g 1 and g foreign-based g3 so
using the first Raptor the simulator can
extract X from this first part and using
the second Raptor the simulator can open
the commitment to any value of his
choice and basically extracting and
extracting a commitment and equivocating
a commitment are the two security
requirements for you see commitment
again this works just if the parties are
similar honest because if the parties
malicious you can put X here and some
other value here right so what we're
going to do is just to reapply the same
idea from before so we're going to have
the sender generate a lot of random
commitments excise you see commitment
x12 you see come between xn and then
you're going to open Alf of those
commitments and check that those are
consistent and again we are going to
randomly partition these commitments
combine them together and they steal
some good commitments from some possibly
bad commitments so basically what i told
you is this legal approach from this
technique that we use in both for the
three plates and for the commitment is
this league approach that we use it also
in this previous paper and this approach
can be thought as you produce a lot of
bricks then you check some of them to
see that they are good and then you
combine these these are the bricks in
order to get an object that that works
even if some of the bricks are not good
as a result we get security against
active adversary in an efficient way and
with this pre-processing paper where you
can actually process all this expensive
all the redundancy all these expensive
replication factors can be pushed at the
beginning of the protocol and and then
when you have the online protocol this
is going to be as secure as they say my
honest protocol basic application of
these approaches of I've been in the
two-party computation case for boolean
circuits MPC for automatic circles that
I told you now the UC commitments as a
building block of this of this protocol
and hopefully I hope that this approach
with this this kind of efficient cutting
choose might find new application in
also the scenarios and I guess it might
actually prefer the probably just prove
is that first us to do the
multiplication okay you start you need
to start with the palette can you do
just proof on for poly that they would
write you could use a large
but I guess the real answer is no we
didn't compare but we just thought that
you know having this poly thing in
between would just break all the all the
proofs that annual but any suggestion
would be highly appreciated
that doesn't maybe we just we have just
chosen the wrong statement to prove
there are two ways of looking at it
right either there are no efficient
proof for our statement or we have
chosen the wrong statements but it seems
that the basic steps so doing the
multiplication and proving that the
multiplication has been done correctly I
don't know how to do that now also
because we don't want to bring the
encryptions on online so there are
efficient proves for palliate okay the
thing is that Polly encryption so we
have poly a in the pre-processing phase
and then in the online phase we just
have the commitments Pelisson
commitments in an Oliver an elliptic
curve and there is a huge gap between
the efficiency of perishing commitment
in elliptic curve and poly encryption
decryption I don't remember the numbers
but you know it's like one top order of
1000 or stuff like that
yeah they are yeah we are there actually
so this work is under submission there
is also another work that is the
implementation and that that is also
under submission yeah yeah i think the
benchmark application was these auctions
the same options as we used in the fifth
case thank you